يا اخواتي مين فيكم صاحيه يا ماما يا
اميره مين انت صاحيه واحده فيكم ترد علي
ولا حد رد علي بسم الله الرحمن الرحيم انا
فاطمه احمد حسني عويده من سكان ابراج دل
الهواء احنا بعد ما قصفوا الجامعه
الاسلاميه والمناطق اللي حواليها كانت
الابراج تتهزهز كانها زلزال من كثر
ضخامه
الانفجارات فلينا على بيت انا وبنتي وزوجي
بالاخر من كثر الشيء قلنا نحن بدنا نخلي
الشقه الشيء قرب
علينا خينا الشقه ونزلنا اخويا كان متصل
علي اخويا راح على الجنوب اتصل علي قال لي
يا اختي بسمع بالاخبار وضع تل الهوا كيف
قال لي يا اختي اذا اضايقت كثير انا هي
بيتي مفتوح روحي عليه وخواتك الثنتين
موجودين فيه ما رضوش يجوا معنا على الجنوب
اللي هي الحاجه سعاد احمد عويضه والحاجه
وداد احمد ع عده رحت انا وبنتي اميره نايف
راضي رحنا قعدنا عندهم كان في يعني شويه
سيارات زوجي جاب سياره ورحنا قعدنا عندهم
هم سكان
اي شارع متفرع من شارع ثمانيه بالقرب من
مصنع اللبن تبع دار دلول رحنا قعدنا
عندهم صار بعد اكم من يوم كان في قصف طبعا
طيران غير شكل في كل غزه يعني مش بس عنا
في المنطقه هذك بعد اكل يوم صار الاجتياح
الاجتياح البري والطيران يقصف والحزام
الناري يجي على
الدور حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل في يوم
23/11
2023 الساعه 2 وربع كانوا بالقبل الايام
قبل التاريخ هذا كل يوم يجوا جرافات
اسرائيليه معهم دبابه وفي قناص فوق برج
دلول اقبال شارع دار اخويا يجوا يجرف
الاراضي والشوارع والبنيه التحت
والمياه وكله واجوا على دار اخويا هدوا
السور وجرف دعسوا على الزراعه ريحان ونعنع
وهذا كله
جرفو خطوط الميه اللي تحت الارض طلعوها
فوق يعني خربوا البنيه التحتيه كلها وهد
سور من الدار من شباك الصالون هد جرفه
زقته وكله وقع فنحنا اصبحنا كاننا قاعدين
في الشارع لانه الدار السور راح
في يوم
2023 احنا كنا كل ما انا وخواتي وبنتي لما
نسمع صوت الجرافه قلبنا يوقع من كثر الخوف
يومها خشوا جرافات كثير قلنا الله يستر ما
يهدموا الدار علينا مش عاملين شي احنا نسء
حريم ايش بدنا
نعمل حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل خشوا الدبابات في ارض زراعيه بعد
دار اخويا بين اخويا له صور الارض
الزراعيه لها صور ومسافه بين كل واح مترين
ثلاثه بيني وبينهم خشوا جرفو بهذه
الارض طولوا قدن العصر ما عرفناش نصلي من
كثر الخوف احنا قاعدين في الاوضه اللي هم
قبال الارض ما علمنا انهم بدهم يخشوا على
الارض هذه يجرفه فكرنا مارقين في الشارع
وبدهم يستمروا في في الطريق ظلهم يجرفه في
الارض يجرفه في الارض لقرب المغرب قبل
المغرب بشويه صاروا يطلعوا الدبابات والله
الجرف صرت اعدهم ثمان جرافات في وده ثابته
كانت بتضل هزين والله حتى الليله وانا
نايمه سمعت صوتها وفزيت من النوم من كتر
صوتها كنت اخاف
منه القناص ما كانش سايبنا كانوا يعملوا
حزام امان للدبابات والجرافات يمروا اطلاق
نار قنابل صوت
قنابل غاز قنابل ما خلى مختص على باب دار
اخويا الحديد يضله يطخطخ عليه بالاخر هذا
القناص نزل على الارض ض وصار يطخطخ على
الحيطان تبع دار
اخوي صاروا الجرافات يطلع قلت لك انا اللي
احنا سمعنا
صوت رجال بتقاتل طلع هذا القناص بده يخش
دارنا كانت الدنيا قرب المغرب بده يخش
دارنا في منهم من اليهود شدوه قالوا له لو
لو لو لو اسمه بيتان هو اللي خاص اسمه
بيتان يقولوا له لو بيتان لو بيتان ما ردش
عليهم خش اختي كانت واقفه ورا الباب
ورافعه شريطه بيضا كده وبنتي حامله شريطه
بيضا وتقول له يش ن شيم يش ن شيم يعني
يوجد نساء ولا ولا اهتم لهذا الكلام انا ح
ساعتها قلت لها يا ماما تعالي اقعدي على
الكرسي بلاش تق الباب فتحه الباب زق الباب
وصار يطخطخ كنا احنا انا اربع افراد انا
وخواتي اثنتين
وبنتي لا اله الا الله بنتي تشهدت قالت
اشهد ان لا اله الا الله واشهد ان محمدا
رسول الله ونامت على الكرسي اللي جنبها ما
عرفتش انا ساعدتها هي استشهدت هي تصوبت ما
عرفتش واختي اللي ورا الباب واقفه الحاجه
وداد قالت لي يا اختي انا متصابه واختي
الثانيه جتلي رصاصه كده كحتت ينها كده
قالتلي يا اختي في هنا جروح جتلي رصاصه ه
قلت لها اه قاعد بيلد وانا اجتلي الرصاصه
انا ق بدي افرجيكم
ايدي هان غزت في رصاصه
وطاريها وصار يسيل دم طبعا
اولها
بعدين شدوه الرجال تعون الجرابات وطلعوه
عاود رجع ثاني وطخ النار عليهم
بزياده انا كنت كانت اختي الي اخت مصليه
العصر وتمددت شويه هيك على جنب التخت اللي
هي الرصاصه اجت على
دقنها لا اله الا
الله انا نمت وراها تمددت
جنبها الحمد لله ما اجت الا لرصاص هذ في
بس اللي هو صار يطخطخ تاني طبعا زادت عدد
الطلقات على اخواتي عودوا شدوه وطلع عود
بعد شويه رجع قال انا ما معناه انا بعرف
بعض كلمات عبره بس ما بعرف كل الكلام اللي
حكاه بس ما معناه انه هنا في اربع فرشات
واللي انا شفتهم ثلاث نساء انا كنت ورا
اختي هو مش
شايفني رجع قاله الواحد منهم تعال ونعدهم
صار يقول له اخذ اتايم شلوش بعدين وقف له
بقول له ها اربع عني انا انا كنت عامله
حالي يعني متمدده وشي بس سامعه الكلام لكن
كان وقف حوالي 20 ثانيه وهو يطلع فيها لكن
20 ثانيه هذه كانهم 20 ساعه ولا 20 سنه من
كتر الخوف اللي انا كنت
خايفه واخذ وطلع وسكر باب الاوضه علينا
كان احنا الاربعه متوفين مش هو اللي سكر
اللي معاه وطلعوا وصارت الدنيا ل الاوضه
عتمت والست ير وقعت وكل كل الاوضه يعني
دمار صارت وكانت لسه الجرافه اللي ثابته
ورا الشباك موجوده ورا دارنا ورا الشباك
ضليتني اس ساكته لاح بدي اطلع ولا صوت ولا
حركه ولا شيء لاحسه يرجعوا لي بعد ما راحت
هذه اللي واقفه
وثابته كانت الدنيا بين المغرب
والعشاء يا اخواتي مين فيكم صاحيه يا ماما
يا اميره مين انت صاحيه واحده فيكم ترد
علي ولا حد رد علي
قلت استشهدوا انا انا مش عارفه وين
اصابتهم كمان مش عارفه ايش اسوي كانت بنتي
قاعده على كرسيين بلاستيك واحد قاعده عليه
والثانيه نامت كده عليه ما بدهاش تشوفه
قومت الله يعزكم بالليل اروح على الحمام
فيش طريق اطلعت لقيت بنتي مرميه على الارض
طب هي كانت قاعده على كراسي زقين موقعين
على الارض ورامين الكرسي كده في اخر
الاوضه جيت جيت اسندها عشان اكلمها اشوفها
لقيت كتفها من ورا من تحت كتف الدم ملا
ايدي حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل عليهم اليهود
حسبنا الله ونعم الوكيل عليهم اليهود
المهم مش مش عارفه وين اصابات خواتي لما
شقشق الصبح ضرتني طول الليل صاحيه طبعا
وانا اترحم عليهم الله يرحمهم ويغفر لهم
يا رب قعد اطلع اخواتي لقيت اختي الحاجه
سعاد جايه لها رصاصه في دقنها ونازله كده
في خدها ونازله كده على الرقبه قدام شارر
كده ولقيت ايدها ايدها من هان من عند
العرق دم بيل و كاينه هي صاحيه وتاخذ
كلينس وتحط عليه اللي عرفني انه اللز
الكلين س ملزق في الدم كانين من هان في
نزيف واختي الثانيه والله ما عرفت وين
اصابتها لقيتها واقعه ورا باب الاوضه اللي
قالت لي يا اختي انا مصوبه ولما اجوا
الشباب وزح نها عشان نلفها بالاحرام
لقيناها تحتها بركه دم والله ما شفت وين
الاصابه من كثر ما هي نزفه دم حسبنا الله
ونعم الوكيل عليهم اليهود بعدين اجينا هنا
على الدار اجوا شباب واخذوني وطلعوني
شوف هي يا خالته شوف
كيف هذا الدم مطرح بعد ما رفعنا
الجثس هذا من المكان هذا في الاوضه هذه
الاوضه في كمان اخت اللي كانت على التخت
هذا التخت ه اللي قلت لك رقبتها وفي ايدها
هان وانا كنت وراها قاعده متمدده بنتي
كانت هان واختي الثانيه هنا هذا دم اختي
وهذا دم بنتي واختي كان دمها على فرشه
التخت اخت الحاجه سعاد عمرها 73 سنه واختي
الحجه وداد عمرها 71 سنه وبنتي 30 سنه
اميره نايف رادي 30 سنه والحمد لله على كل
حال الله يا رب يصبرنا يا رب ويرحمهم
ويغفرلهم ويوسع مدخلهم يا رب ويثبتهم عند
السؤال يا رب ويتقبلهم مع الشهداء
والصالحين حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل هو بس انتقامه اجرامه نزيه هم
بقولوا انه هم هم عانوا من النزيه عملوا
نزيه اكبر من كده حسبنا الله ونعم
الوكيل